hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I'm so excited because this is a
very special unboxing this is parked
advice part unboxing video I partnered
with the Microsoft Store to talk to you
guys about things that I wish that I had
known when I went to school they also
let me pick out some things from the
Microsoft Store that I wish that I had
when I was in school and these are some
of the items that I picked for a little
bit of context I went to a tech school
so it was two-year school so basically
you went to school for two years
straight you have a little bit of a
break in the summer but maybe like two
weeks or something and then right back
to work so it was cool about this
program that I did is very very
dedicated very focused to the things
that I was most interested in learning
obviously if you can guess by my career
path I would just go for design video
production we also did 3d we did web
development we did so many things in
those two years but I also want you to
remember that this was a long time ago
but it feels like a very long time ago I
think I graduated in 2004 but what's
been great about that it's seeing the
technology change so quickly
so before we start this unboxing my
number one tip that I wish that I would
have told myself was to save all of your
files backup all of your data all the
time as soon as possible as often as you
can
because now I wish that I had the photos
back then I took in school I wish that I
had those project files that I worked on
I do have some a lot of the websites
back then they don't even exist now so
places that I had uploaded photos to or
project files
they don't exist anymore so I have no
way to have that information back safe
and save often especially in a field
where you're doing a lot of projects in
Photoshop in Final Cut in Premiere
thankfully now autosave is a very
prevalent feature where back then that
wasn't a thing if you didn't save and
save often you'd be in trouble and
unfortunately I was not one of those
that saved often one piece of tech that
I wish I had was this is an unboxing
because I've talked about this many many
times is something like this this is
surface book - I absolutely love this
especially because I'm a designer
this little guy would have been quite
the savior because not only is it a
computer it's also a tablet chose these
items to go with my surface this is when
the Microsoft Surface Arc Mouse's mice
not I also got this one it's like Pro
Mouse and to go with this surface book
because this pops them off okay this is
there's a lot of here and turns into a
tablet if I had this back when I was
doing illustrations I can't even I just
I don't want to be one of those elderly
people that's like back in my day
because back in my day I don't even want
to tell you the things that we had to do
our computers were running so slow I was
storing things on zip drives oh could
have been worse I could have been
storing them on floppy drives or it
could have even been way worse didn't
even have computers we did it let's
unbox these guys this house I'm so
excited about this so this mouse I'll
probably actually end up using with my
surface studio because I really liked it
has extra buttons here on the side and
it's nice a precision wheel that is so
smooth oh this thing is fantastic and
even though they had this it's so cool
because they turn it on you just bend it
and if it's to your hand
actually looks like it's gonna match my
knife perfectly one of the other tips
that I would tell myself that I wish
that I had known when I was in school I
feel like I was a little bit antisocial
it wasn't because I didn't want to talk
to people I just felt like I was sort of
very secluded and I was a little bit shy
which is kind of shocking because you
guys know me as me this person on the
Internet right now I'm talking to a
camera real-life Justine is a little bit
more shy and she's actually an introvert
talking about myself in the third person
wish that I wouldn't fit
we'll get more outgoing talk to people a
little bit more and made more friends
and they definitely had a lot of friends
but I feel like there were people that I
didn't talk to because they didn't talk
to me and they also I think we're shy so
when two shy people are met with each
other it usually doesn't work out that
well so I think that's something that I
wish that I would have done is talk to
more people okay it definitely matches
my knife everybody needs a stylist that
matches there so I worked a lot in
college and it was hard because being a
student and then trying to live and
survive that is such a difficult balance
and I feel like that's also a hard
balance actually be out of school but
one of the things that I did do it I did
a lot of freelance work and what's
incredible now is there are so many ways
to make money there's so many things
like postmates and uber and lyft to be
able to have these opportunities at your
fingertips take advantage of those I did
a lot of freelance so I was making
websites for people and things like that
I wish the opportunities that you have
nailed with technology and different
ways to have jobs but you guys do have
that available so if you're in that
position where you do need a job there's
an app for that
this is something that I got really
excited about and I know it's surprising
but it's office 365 it's a home
subscription this is the first time I've
unboxed a subscription just let it be an
omen has anybody else inboxes
subscriptions so this also works with
Windows and Mac which is great because I
can put this on my Mac and my PC this is
great because you can get it for five
users what's gonna be inside here I'm
assuming that this is my download code
right here my product key is here Shh I
can't see it it's a secret another thing
that I wish that I had known or told
myself
his health is very very important I feel
like I definitely I don't want to say
that I let myself go in college things I
do have a very fast metabolism but I did
not get very healthy and I think that's
something that is so important and it is
hard
as a college student in the major that I
was in I was sitting on the computer
hours and hours and he was still sitting
on it hours and hours in a day the
trying to find that fine balance between
work working out and trying to somewhat
eat healthy was a huge struggle so I
wish that that was something that I
didn't pay a little bit more attention
to and I didn't it's never too late to
start I've been eyeing these up for
awhile these are the quiet comfort 35 to
annoys cancelling headphones most likely
you probably have roommates and
sometimes they may be a little bit
difficult to get along with if you do
have incredible roommates you guys were
so lucky
I think totally didn't have very bad
roommates at all I would be editing a
lot and I would be able to hear
everything I had to share a room with a
girl and we were very very close
together so I sort of had this bed that
was over top of my computer so it's kind
of like bunk beds
my better than the top computer was at
the bottom and she was little right next
to me and I would be up and editing and
working very very late into the night so
being able to have these notes can play
headphones I wouldn't be able to hear
anything which I didn't have then so it
was a problem I was a college student
and there is absolutely no way that I
could even afford these trying to save
money trying to work and really make
ends meet and also have time to do other
things a lot of people do struggle with
finding the job and finding the career
path and finding things and finding ways
to make money it isn't easy but finding
that passion and finding a love for the
work that you're doing is so important
so whatever it is that you absolutely
love whatever it is that you're
passionate about find a way to make that
your career whatever it is all my life I
have absolutely loved it video games
I have loved making videos I've loved
making people laugh and smile and just
being able to take technology and make
it sort of my job has been such a dream
come true and I just wish that for
absolutely everyone to find that thing
that it is that makes you happy
and be able to do that whoo oh wow I
love the smell of new tech
just it's just a dream um okay well
download the Bose connect ok turn my
product on oh this is gonna be the
longest video ever
pretty deep air oh my gosh ok I hear
talking to me oh I love that it has the
R and L in there too bad I get my listen
rights because I don't talk about it
whoa baby I haven't had a pair of
noise-canceling headphones in such a
long time plate clanks Tov Everest I
haven't had a good pair of headphones in
a very very long time I was just doing
that so I can make a Jif out of it okay
well wow I must have been yelling these
are shockingly incredible now how do I
work this thing next up is the razor
phone I'm actually really excited about
this I was gonna unbox it here but I
feel like this is gonna be something
that I do really want to do a dedicated
video for but I cannot wait to try this
out I was so surprised when I saw this
was on the Microsoft Store I still could
not believe all of the things that they
had on there and I mean yes they did
sponsor this video but I am still
shocked at the amount of things that
they had because before this and I think
about the Microsoft Store I was just
thinking about buying Xbox games or
things like that but they have a lot of
products but look for this in a later
video because I feel like the videos
couldn't be so long
but speaking of cell phones when I was
in school I didn't even have a phone my
mom actually had to make me get a phone
because she wasn't able to get in touch
with me so she gave me one of her old
Motorola I was like a star something or
other I don't even remember what it was
but it was her old phone and then as
soon as I discovered text messaging I
was like this is life-changing but you
guys remember t9 I was so fast I was
just going like that I wonder if I want
to so how's that phone but this is
definitely a piece of advice that I
would give myself when I was going to
now whatever you post on the Internet it
does not go away you might want to think
twice about your future self because you
made completely entirely ruin your life
by posting something on the Internet if
you think for a second you shouldn't
post it don't post it that is my advice
to you guys moving along to our last
piece of tech that I am incredibly
excited about I've seen these in several
people's YouTube videos before and the
backgrounds of their videos and I didn't
even know what it was this is the JBL
pulse 3 it's a portable Bluetooth
speaker but what is it great about this
is it lights up
I can't wait this is so cool another
piece of advice that I would give to my
future self or to you guys school is
stuff but real life is way more
difficult learn as much as you can but
just know that the things that you do
learn in school most of the times a lot
of that stuff you're not ever even going
to apply it in your real life in your
career but a lot of times you're set
that you're learning if stuff that you
have to do just to get through classes
finish those courses
honestly learn as much as you can if
there's something that you're interested
in find a class take a class in that
thing there's so many things that I'm
thinking about now like I really want to
start taking some coloring classes I've
been looking into taking DaVinci Resolve
classes and to be able to have that all
at your fingertips out of school at a
university is really incredible I think
what's great is no matter what your ages
you really don't ever have to stop
learning you can basically learn
anything from the internet JBL I hope
that you have some power oh my gosh this
is amazing
another thing that I definitely wish
that I had learned or knew a lot of
people learn differently I don't learn
the same
as most people do I was not a very good
book person you could put a book in
front of me and I could read it and then
take a test and I would probably fail so
listening to audio and things like that
so a lot of times I wish that I would
have recorded some of my classes and
been able to just sort of go back and
listen that's how I learned you can
figure out the way that you learn best
and apply that to your classes
that is such an important thing JBL I'm
looking for you oh here you are
what looks like something it is drink
this is something that Starbucks should
have they should have JBL pulse three
drinks plate clanks Tov Everest no
called uh oh my god I'm calling dr.
Everett no I don't even know a dr.
Everett but they were really cool when I
was in school everybody had them if we
went into somebody's dorm room or
apartment I think everybody had one okay
I think you so much for watching and it
was kind of a random video well if I can
leave you with any piece of advice is
have fun and learn as much as you can in
school and then people that you meet
there you never know when you're gonna
run into them later in life it is kind
of cool to see especially now with
social media and Facebook and Twitter in
it everything is you get to stay with
these people you will always know what
someone is up to if they're posting of
course is not everyone is on social
media which is kind of crazy when I meet
somebody when they like move I don't
tweet I don't post on Instagram like who
are you how do you do that I would love
to hear from you guys some of your
school struggles what are some advice
that you guys would give people going
back to school leave those in the
comments below
I look forward to reading them also let
me know what's your major what are you
going to school for what did you go to
school for it is also kind of crazy
because you can go to school for
something and then never actually ever
do that thing like my sister she went to
school for oh my god it she's like three
degrees or something like speech
pathology a biology degree and a
forensics degree and now she's making
YouTube videos you never know
the world is your oyster I tried to
think of a motivational quote I don't
think I did a very good job anyway
I see you guys later bye
[Music]
you